[Music]
let's see here let's go
actually no
oh hey if y'all want to know how the
show actually works it's that
kelly coming in going actually no
we decided that since we have to sit
here and listen who's we
the collective
control room oh the board people yes
okay um that we have to sit here and
listen to this so occasionally we should
get
to ask a question but we have to listen
this is fantastic we have yes that we
should get to ask a question if we have
questions about you know the fall within
the
the topics so
nathan we literally were hanging all
right let's do it i know but nathan has
a great question that we thought was
excellent and worth being on the air all
right let's do it what's up by the way
nathan is the youtube guru he runs all
these cameras and switches them and
lights and everything it's good to see
it man okay see you too what's up
all right so
we have metrics for physical health when
it comes to heart rate calories weight
all that stuff how do we track when we
know that we have become mentally
healthy
do you have an example of that
um
got an example of that
like how do you know when you get there
wherever like like you okay so
let me see if this is what you're asking
if you wanted to you're a pretty buff
guy but you're like i want to put on 25
more pounds of raw american beef muscle
right and you went to the gym
and you lifted a lot you would have a a
scale
and you would have a number of workouts
that you did and you would be able to
say i made this goal or i didn't make
this goal
but when you
and your wife are like we want to be
mentally well i want to have good mental
health
what is like how do we know when we got
there is that what you're asking yeah so
it's like if you're in
if you know you're not in a
good place in your mental health
and you start that process of becoming
mentally healthy
how do you know when you've gotten to a
place where you are ah okay all right
so i think it's important that's a great
question man good call you should have
called into the show that's great
um okay so here's my answer to that just
off top of my head number one
um
mental health is a process it's a it's a
state of doing it is not a destination
um you will never get to
like i'm mentally well there's not
people yelling that on rooftops
um
it's a process because the moment you
think like oh i'm great that's when you
walk out in the parking lot and somebody
texts you and says hey mom's got cancer
that's when you find out your friend
just got a car wreck right that's life
happens over and over and over again
so dealing with those things up and down
up and down doesn't mean you're not
mentally healthy right or mentally well
so mental health is a process it's a
thing that you do it's not a destination
you can never quote unquote get there
um
here's that interesting thing i was just
talking to somebody about this the other
day so
part of me unspooling back in 2008 and
2009
was my i grew up um we had a lot of
financial challenges growing up my dad
was just a police officer we i think we
made like 22 grand we didn't make a lot
of money and we struggled a lot
financially growing up
so i have a built-in narrative him that
my body responds to that
money
is is a trigger across the board for me
it just always has been
2008 and 2009 i was coming into my own
as a young professional i was over
things having to deal with budgets for
the first time in personnel for the
first time
and everything fell apart right and i
just bought another house and everything
in the country fell apart so i was
listening to students come from all over
the country and their parents were going
to pull them out of school and people's
home equities were falling apart it was
just a mess
and my body responded as though this the
apocalypse is upon us right
and that came out as anxiety that came
out as extreme ocd that came out of
seasons of running really low and being
burned out i've always had adhd so any
diagnosis you can throw at it man i was
all over the place
the journey out of that
so now we're entering into at the
entering a recession inflation's crazy
there's economic issues everywhere
i was just talking to someone the other
day
after a decade of learning how to sleep
learning the importance of having
friends and making that a regular
priority the importance of having a
daily
exercise routine being conscious of what
i eat and what i put into my head right
whether that's if i just listen to
pantera 24 7 i'm going to be a little
more of an angry guy right um
if uh if i watch the news 24 7 i'm going
to be raged out i'm going to it's going
to spin my brain up
so
the process of me getting well has just
been a continuation so the facts
haven't changed the economy is a mess
and it's about to get gnarly for a
season
here's how i know i am on a path of
wellness my body's not reacting as
though it's the end of time does that
make sense and so when somebody says how
do i know if i'm mentally well if i'm
healthy
can your body hear
can your body hear these stories can
your body be faced with reality
and can it respond a spot respond
appropriately is that fair does that
make sense
so if my wife gets in a car wreck today
and passes away
i don't want to put that in the universe
but let's say that happens an
appropriate response for my body will be
to shut down in the black hole of grief
for a long time
and have to deal with two little kids
and all that stuff that would be
appropriate
the
process of dealing with inflation
economy or whatever
now i'm going to deal with it and my
body's not taking off i'm just going to
deal with it with the facts i have in
front of me and i'm just going to live
that way
and i'm going to keep doing
doing the things that helped me be well
does that answer your question is that
helpful
yeah yeah
i feel like i talk around do that i
don't know you're laughing kelly
this doesn't do great no i thought that
was great okay
um how do you know when you're mentally
well
on those rare rare moments
when that happens
i think um
it's when i feel that i've a
kind of what you said when i feel like
i've responded
not even to a crisis because you know
just life just life appropriately
because you know when you don't respond
appropriately you know and you're like
wow that was way out of line yeah when i
feel like i've responded appropriately
and also when i
a lot with me is when i feel like i'm
doing okay when i can say well i messed
that up or
i know i apologize to my kids because i
acted you know i yelled when i shouldn't
have or whatever so so it's really
trying to keep my body out of fight or
flight whenever possible right or only
going into fight or flight when
necessary right
and yeah that's that tells me that's the
metric if you will that i'm on the path
and i do think some of the metrics like
for heart rate variability they tell me
if my body's functioning okay the scale
is but one data point that tells me
hey man
it's higher than it was
that tells me you're f you're not you're
heading off into the past it's great man
that's good data point that means so all
these data points they still work but
there's no end goal to quote unquote
mental health it's a daily
it's a it's a daily path that we walk
right is that does that make sense
and you've got four kids so
good luck with that
good luck with that hey thanks for the
question man you should call into the
show you should work on this show man
i'm just kidding i'm glad you're here